- I want to be completely honest with you.
If you plan to stay in
consulting for the long-term,
you will be not set up well
for a general management career.
You will lack crucial
skills that are required
to run large organizations
that you will not build in consulting,
even if you work for a
leading strategy consulting firm
such as McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
Hi guys, my name is Heinrich
and welcome to another
coffee break with me
here on my channel Firm Learning.
On this channel I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
I do that by drawing from my experience,
having worked at McKinsey as
consultant for several years
and now in a C-level position
at a German retailer.
Today I'm talking about the downsides
of working in consulting,
and here I'm not
referring to the lifestyle
or to the work-life balance
or anything like that.
But I'm talking about the
things that you do not learn
if you work in a consulting firm.
You know that I'm quite
positive about my time
in consulting at McKinsey,
and I even made a whole video about
why I believe that consulting
is the right first career step
for most business graduates
fresh out of university.
If you have not seen that yet,
I will insert a link to that
video somewhere above here.
Check it out because I really
believe that consulting
is a great opportunity
for most of you out there.
After I made this first
video about consulting,
you reached out to me and you asked me
to do this other video as well.
To also talk about the downsides,
and you know that if you ask
me I will deliver for you.
So before I tell you the three things
that I believe you will
not learn in consulting,
please like the video
for the YouTube algorithm
if you're getting any
value out of it at all.
And please also subscribe to my channel
to stay up to date with
all my video updates.
I will release at least
one video every week
and if you wanna get even
more content from me,
follow me on my Instagram.
The handle is @firmlearning
on my Instagram I'm posting
new content for your daily
to help you to become
successful in the first
years of your career.
But this does not mean
that working in consulting
is like a fairy tale and
you will learn everything
you need for your future.
And specifically I believe
there are three things,
three very important
skills and capabilities
that you will not build
if you stay in consulting
for the longterm.
My career recommendation
therefore is that yes,
a few years in consulting
will make a lot of sense for most people,
but after a couple of years in consulting.
It is probably not a bad idea
to look for a more operational role
to build your full skill set.
But let's now dive into it.
Let's talk about the top three things
that you do not learn in consulting
and these are not some minor things,
but these are things that I
believe are really crucial
and are really important for you
to become a well rounded general manager.
The first aspect is team leadership,
and here I wanna mention that
there are two facets of that.
So the one facet is the positive facet
because the positive side of
working in consulting is that
pretty quickly after
only a couple of years
of being a regular consultant,
you will usually advance into
the rank of a project lead.
And this will mean that
you will be responsible
of a team of usually two
to four other consultants
working on the ground at the
client site on your project.
And this is an opportunity
for team leadership experience
that you will get much quicker,
than compared to most
other industry roles
where usually it takes much
longer until you really get
team leadership responsibility
for a team of people
in your company.
So why this is the positive
side of team leadership
when you work in consulting.
The other facet is
what type of team leadership
experience you get.
So here you need to think
about what types of people,
what types of colleagues you will lead,
especially if you work for one of the
leading consulting firms
such as McKinsey, BCG or Bain
or MBB as they're also often referred to.
Pretty much all of the people
that you are working with
in these firms are so
called high potentials.
This means that they are graduates
from leading universities
around the world.
Most of them ranked in the top
10% of their university class.
Many of them had highly
competitive scholarships,
they have already
collected work experience
in high profile internships.
And most of them have quite impressive
extracurriculars as well.
These are the people
that may be your team,
and this means that your team
will be just highly motivated
whenever you just tip them
in one direction as a project lead,
they will run,
they will work day and night for you.
They will do whatever they can
to get a good result for
the client and for the team.
While I do not want to say
that being a project lead
at an MBB consulting
firm is an easy endeavor,
leading and motivating
your consulting colleagues
is probably not one of
the most challenging
leadership activities out there.
If you then later want to
transition into industry
or startup into a more
general manager type of role,
the situation that you
will find yourself in
will be significantly different.
And while of course in industry
you can find some highly capable,
motivated and professional
colleagues as well,
it is fair to say that you will
meet and you will work with
many people who are
significantly less motivated,
significantly less driven
than your average colleague
at an MBB consulting firm.
And this is now where
your real leadership
abilities need to shine.
This is really a challenge
and this is what you need to learn
to succeed in such a role.
For most of your consulting colleagues
while you're in consulting,
the work, at least within the workweek
is the priority number one.
But the average person in
industry maybe has a family,
maybe has other life priorities as well,
and this is completely fine
and completely understandable.
But you just need to recognize
as a leader that the mindset of the people
that you work with will
just be a different one,
and you need to adapt to that
and to change your
leadership style accordingly.
And for these reasons,
I believe that the team
leadership experience
that you get when working in consulting
it's not worthless,
but it's not directly applicable
to a regular industry or startup context.
Leading MBB consulting
teams is really not the same
as working with a large
organization of 20, 30, 40 people,
with a big variety of
educational backgrounds
and skill sets.
You really need to get this
broader leadership experience
firsthand to become a well
rounded business professional.
The second thing that you're
not learning in consulting
is Operations.
In your daily work as a consultant
there's a clear lack of focus
on operational activities.
What do I mean by that?
If you work in consulting,
and this is especially true
for MBB strategy consulting,
but also for most other types
of consulting engagements,
what you deliver in the end?
Our concepts, our strategies
in the end of course
you also wanna help your client
implement the things that you recommend,
but the deliverables that you leave
will usually be pieces of
papers, they're concepts.
As a consultant you usually walk around
with the mindset that the difficult
the challenging part is to
come up with these concepts
that you develop.
And then the execution,
well that's for the other people to do
this is just about implementing
what you told them to do.
It's not especially difficult
or challenging, right?
Though the truth is that as a consultant
you are often significantly
underestimating
how difficult it is to really execute.
To really implement these ideas
and I want to illustrate
that with a little example
that I experienced myself
when then later I transitioned
from the consulting role
into an operational role in industry.
I was responsible for
an eCommerce operation
and we wanted to introduce
PayPal as a way of payment
in the online store.
How would you do that as a consultant?
Probably you would write a report
in which you recommend a couple of things
that the client should do.
And then one of the things
you could improve on
would be to offer a larger
variety of payment options
for your clients.
And then probably in one bullet point,
you would write that
PayPal should be introduced
as a payment option.
And when I was a consultant,
I probably would have thought
that implementing PayPal
would take you one or two weeks,
maybe three weeks
if there were some big
unexpected problems coming up.
But implementing PayPal
as a payment option
should be rather easy.
So this was the mindset that I
had when I worked in industry
and I wanted now to implement PayPal
as new payment option
for our online store.
And then I learned what
all of this really meant.
This meant that we needed
to implement new interfaces
between our online eCommerce solution
and the accounting system
that we were using.
We needed to work together
with external service providers
to make sure that this
interface was running smoothly.
Then we found out that the
legacy accounting system
that we were using was not able to support
an additional way of payment.
It had a fixed number of
slots for payment options
that you could use and implement,
but these were already taken
so you couldn't just set
up a new way of payment.
So now we needed to find a workaround
in the accounting system in order for us
to now implement payment
as a new payment option.
Then there were also some
struggles with PayPal itself
because we needed to include
different types of bank accounts.
And we found out that the person
who initially set up the
PayPal account needed to be
the exact person on which the bank account
then was set as well.
And this alone took us weeks
until we figured it out
with the PayPal support
that all the accounts were
registered with the right names
and everything was running
on the PayPal end the way it should.
So instead of only one or two weeks
before we could offer
PayPal to our customers,
it took us more than three months
before we really were able to offer PayPal
as a payment option to our customers.
As a consultant, you do
not see these things.
You regularly significantly underestimate
the pain and the
difficulties of implementing
the suggestions that you make,
and when you then later
transition into an industry role,
this will fall on your feet badly.
You're just not used
to implement your ideas
to execute your ideas
and this is a problem.
This is the type of experience
that you only get in an operational role
and you don't get this
exposure working in consulting.
The third thing that in my opinion,
you do not learn properly
from working in consulting,
is the value of agility and speed.
Usually especially if you work at MBB,
but also other consulting firms,
you work for rather large corporations.
You learn how to align things
with lots of different stakeholders.
You learn how the
decision making processes
in these kinds of companies work,
and of course this is a
valuable skill in itself
But especially if you later
want to work in a startup
or in a smaller company
in these companies,
other things are important.
These companies often
put a lot of emphasis
on the Silicon Valley value of moving fast
and breaking things.
And it's often better to
just getting things done
than getting them right perfectly.
And this of course is not the mindset
that large corporations have.
Also because of their size and
because of other implications
if things go wrong and the
rigor of internal alignment
and quality assurance processes.
These companies often
teach you to be cautious,
to be sure that your cover your back,
that you made sure that you
checked all the possible things
that could go wrong before you
come up with a new concept,
and then propose it to
the senior management.
In the smaller companies,
being thorough and being diligent
in this way is often not that important.
You need to be fast,
you need to be quick,
you need to be agile,
you need to do five things
and then be okay if two things don't work,
but the other three things do.
And this is a skill
that requires a certain street smartness,
a certain way of doing things,
which doesn't put focus
so much on being polished,
on being corporate,
but just getting things done.
And this is the agile startup mentality
that you will lack
from working in most
consultancies out there.
But that is so valuable for
many many roles out there.
Many companies, especially if
you wanna work for a startup
or smaller company and not for
a big corporate in the end.
So these were the three things
that you do not learn in consulting,
first team leadership,
second focus on operation and third,
the agility and the startup mindset
that you will just not have in the way
that you will have it in other companies.
As you know I only started this channel
a couple of month ago
and I'm very interested
to hear your feedback of
how I should further develop the channel.
What types of content you
are especially interested in.
So if you have any opinion on that,
leave a comment below
in the comment section,
or go to the community tab
because I released a survey
there a couple of days ago,
where you can give me your
opinion on what type of content
you would like to see more in the future.
Now, I would be very interested
to hear your perspective.
So for those of you who
worked in consulting as well,
do you agree with that?
Do you also believe that
these are the downsides
of working in consulting, the
things that you do not learn?
Would you like to add any more things
that you believe I've
missed in this video?
Let me know if you have
any questions as well.
I will answer every single
comment that you write me.
Please if you enjoyed this video,
leave a like for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to the channel
and turn on the notification bell.
Because otherwise YouTube
might not show you
every single video that I released,
even if you subscribe to my channel.
And of course also follow
my Instagram channel.
The handle is @firmlearning
if you wanna see even
more content from me.
Thank you for watching.
I very much appreciate your time.
It has been a pleasure to
make this video for you
and have a good day.